if you've seen the trailer for Avengers
and game then you've gotten a glimpse of
Clint Barton's return but the man
previously known as Hawkeye is very
likely returning to the MCU with a whole
new codename ronan if you're wondering
what the deal is with this mysterious
new persona you're probably not alone
let's break down the history of this
Marvel Comics Samurai
Clint Barton isn't the first Marvel
Comics character to wear the mask of
ronan bald Aronian identity wouldn't
appear in comic books until 2005 the
first character to wear the costume
debuted in 1999 her name was Maya Lopez
also known as echo and she made her
first appearance and the pages of
daredevil issue 9 though Maya is deaf
she has the ability to exactly mimic any
action she's ever seen from Jackie Chan
stuns to Liberace's piano playing when
she met Matt Murdock a better known as
daredevil
the attraction was immediate and the two
promptly fell in love unfortunately like
many of Matt Murdock's relationships
this romance it didn't end well
Maya was manipulated by the kingpin into
believing that daredevil had killed her
father a mind game that convinced her to
try and kill the vigilante she soon
found out that the kingpin himself was
the one who killed her father so she
shot him in the face and then vanished
for a while but if there's a stunning
woman with questionable character in the
room Matt Murdock's gonna find her and
foggy Nelson is gonna suffer alright I
don't disagree with anything you say
Brandon's first outing came in the pages
of New Avengers during a battle against
Hydra at the hand and the Yakuza
affiliated Yoshida clan
Captain America recruited the mysterious
fighter onto the Avengers
thanks to a reference from daredevil
during Ronan's first appearance her real
identity was kept a mystery with readers
left to puzzle out just who this new
hero was with a loose-fitting costume
featuring a full face mask it could have
been anyone the mystery established that
Ronin wasn't just a new superhero it was
an identity that any Marvel character
could use for covert purposes with
several unexpected heroes wearing the
mask in the years to come the 2004 story
arc Avengers disassembled resulted in
the apparent deaths of multiple Avengers
including Scott Lang the vision and
Hawkeye but death is rarely a permanent
condition in comic books with Hawkeye
returning to life a thanks to the
reality altering powers of the
which no no this makes sense when
clint's came back to life he had trouble
returning to his work as Hawkeye Farley
because a new hero Kate Bishop had taken
on the Hawkeye name for herself as a
member of the Young Avengers while
everyone would eventually agree that the
world was just fine with two hawkeye's
Clint didn't feel that way at first
before taking up his old name again he
also did a stretch as Ronin after Clint
met the first Ronan during a rescue
mission she passed a costume on to him
explaining that the identity had served
its purpose for her it was his to use
for as long as he needed it Clint
reverted to his Hawkeye identity in 2010
when the Avengers reformed after the
events of Civil War while this marked
the end of Clint tenure as the hero it
was not the end of Ronan the next time
Ronan showed up was drawing the
Widowmaker crossover in 2010 the Black
Widow centric story kicked off for the
murder of several Russian spies by a
group led by Ronan when a team of
Russian superheroes tried to arrest
Hawkeye for the killings everyone soon
realized that someone else was wearing
the mask this new Ronan was a leader of
a criminal group called the dark ocean
society this time Ronan's real identity
was Alexi szostak off also known as the
first red Guardian that character can be
seen as the Soviet Union's answer to
Captain America and he was also the
black widows ex-husband his plan as
Ronan was to use the dark ocean society
to restore Russia to its former Soviet
glory but the heroes were able to take
him down
they also apparently took the Ronan
costume back home with them putting it
in a box for a couple years
Avengers HQ maybe they just thought it
looks cool or maybe they thought it
would come in handy later
[Music]
when the Mighty Avengers series
relaunched in 2013 they were accompanied
by a new mysterious hero
this fighter kept his identity secret to
avoid attention from his enemies the
mysterious death Walker's so he grabbed
the first costume that was available a
neon green and pink bootleg spider-man
costume with spider hero written on the
chest spider hero was a confusing
character both for comic book readers
and the characters teammates and like
other spider people he didn't climb
walls or shoot webs and instead he beats
a bad guy with a pair of nunchucks
basically behaving more like a ninja
turtle than a Spider Man making things
more mysterious he also seemed to have
some knowledge of the mystical arts the
spider hero costume that didn't last too
long in the series by the fourth issue
the mysterious good guy was gifted the
ronin costume to help keep his identity
a secret in a slightly more
professional-looking way
finally in Mighty Avengers issue 9 the
identity of this masked man was revealed
he was none other than Erik Brooks
better known to most audiences as a
vampire slayer' blade you gotta be
kidding me the end game trailer finally
answers the question of what Clint
Barton has been up to since the events
of Captain America Civil War his outfit
sure seems to look like their own in
costume but what inspired him to take up
the sword we have an idea but it's not a
pleasant one Avengers age of Ultron
showed us a Hawkeye had a whole life
outside of his work as a covert
operative with a beautiful family on a
peaceful farm after he was arrested at
the end of civil war he retired to be
with his wife and children sitting out
infinity war until a furnace one it
seems very likely that Quinn's family
was a part of the 50% of life but Thanos
decimated meaning that Clint ought to
watch them fade away into dust the
horror of that seems like more than
enough to inspire Clint to take on a
darker identity go to another country
and start stabbing people did he succeed
in beating fellows where the others
failed well it's worth a shot
this can't seem to miss